also since mana mana hey Ron i'ma be
sharp welcome to Abby's kitchen today
I'm back with another what a in a date
youtuber view and today I'm gonna be
talking about high carb Hannah high carb
pana was in high demand in the comments
section on my video so here we are
so Hannah talks a lot about in her
videos having gone through a really kind
of extreme diet overhaul she lost 70
pounds after starting a low oil
plant-based whole food diet she also has
a lot of cool videos about living in a
tiny house off the grid and she talks a
lot about having a healthy relationship
with food however at the same time
that's juxtapose against having a lot of
videos on weight loss hacks and celery
juice cleanses and potato detoxes and
intermittent fasting and detox is in
general so you probably can guess what I
have to say about that but without a do
I'm going to get into her what I eat in
a day video let's do this let's start
with breakfast decide between oats or
smoothie so I can buy them so good I
basically it just blended some bananas
berries and protein powder with a little
bit of water and then I cooked some
instant oats in a separate Bowl and just
left them in there to cool for a tiny
bit and thicken I poured the smoothie on
half of it and the oats on the other
half and then I topped it with some
fresh berries and peanut butter a little
bit of enjoy life chocolate chips and
some coconut and let me tell you guys
this was the most amazing combo ever I
feel like because it was hot and cold
and more savoury but more sweet and had
all these like toppings on it I love it
I love her like Zen moment around this
breakfast but honestly this looks like
really good I love the idea of combining
a smoothie with your oatmeal I like
foods that you can like eat with a spoon
more than just kind of like chug back
like a smoothie I just find it's more
emotionally and like satisfying so I
think this is actually a great option so
we've got lots of good things going on
we've got the energizing carbs and
antioxidants from all the berries and
of course also from the oats we've got
some fiber in there we've got protein
from the protein powder and the and the
nut butter we've got healthy fats from
the nut butter and the coconut it looks
awesome
but just in a really healthy way and
then I took my vitamins I typically like
to wait until I eat something to take
them just because I feel like they
digest better but I know it's like not
necessary it's just I like to have
something in my stomach when I take my
vitamins if you guys saw my video so
there is some truth to this some
vitamins and minerals may kind of be
easier on the stomach when taken with
food or went after food has been in the
stomach so things like iron would be a
really good example of that other
vitamins might be absorbed a little bit
better depending on what food you eat so
things like vitamins A D and K or your
fat soluble vitamins and then your water
soluble vitamins are a little bit more
easygoing so things like B vitamins C
folate etc so you can take those
whenever you want so on supplements I
was taking the ritual essential women's
supplement and I just switched to their
prenatal because obviously Derrick and I
are still trying to have a baby and
we're trying really hard not pregnant
yet but I figured I might as well take a
prenatal and I didn't even know that
they made a prenatal so I started taking
this about a month ago I really like the
fact that it doesn't make me feel
nauseous
I have taken prenatal in the past
because I used to think that they would
like make my hair and my nails stronger
but they always made me really nauseous
so this one definitely has no nausea
effect to it and I'm in love with them
obviously when we're trying to have a
baby or even pregnant getting the right
amount of nutrients and vitamins is
essential to the development of the baby
but also ourselves and I didn't actually
know this but the ideal time to start
taking a prenatal is about three months
before you want to get pregnant so I'm
glad that Hannah mentions this because I
have a very unflattering shotty I'm
sorry Hannah honey but I'm glad that she
mentions this because it is really
important that if you're trying to
conceive a baby
or even if you are sexually active
enough childbearing age
you know it's important to take a
prenatal vitamin because mistakes can
happen right I mentioned this in a
previous video but it is really
important to prevent neural defects and
of course for the development of the
baby and I just took a quick look at the
ritual vitamins that she's mentioning
and they look like a good option for
vegans because they have a vegan source
of iron and vitamin d3 which is not
always the case for all prenatal
supplements so one thing I do in a flag
is that Hannah mentions that she's
trying really hard to get pregnant with
her partner however the title of this
video is what to eat what I in a day to
stay lean and healthy which i think is a
bit counterproductive fertility requires
body fat so if you're trying to conceive
and you haven't had success I highly
suggest seeking out some help from your
doctor finding out you know through
blood work what are your cortisol levels
your LH or estrogen because low body fat
can interfere with these hormones and
make it difficult to have regular
ovulation or maintain a healthy
pregnancy I am going to be making a
whole video about fertility in the
future because as a fellow infertility
warrior I know a lot if you're not
considering pregnancy I highly also
recommend rituals essential women's
daily vitamin that I was taking for a
few months before I started taking this
I will link the video where I talked
about that down below and how it helped
me to fix a iron deficiency that I okay
so I'm glad she mentioned kind of iron
deficiency and and taking supplements
however I want to flag that before you
go into taking any kind of supplements
always speak to your health care
provider if you're self diagnosing
yourself as being iron deficient because
of some of the common symptoms of anemia
like being tired weak chest pains pale
etc just know that it's not actually
always iron that is the issue it could
also be kidney issues pregnancy it could
be potentially like ulcers it could be
medications cancer or even a b12
deficiency so always get your numbers
checked if you're unsure alright let's
get into lunch
so I'm having this Thai salad it's made
with like this really good ginger carrot
tahini dressing that is out of this
world I mean should I say everything's
actually smoked but like this dressing
is my one of my favorites and I like to
make it in big batches and it's really
gonna help noodles or pasta noodles I
also put it on just tofu and steamed
veggies is really good so what I have in
here is some spring greens tofu a lemon
mmm cat hair a loving heart like tofu
that I need some edamame cucumber sesame
seeds cilantro and red onion this so
that cell looks amazing we've got lots
of protein from the edamame and the tofu
tons of greens in there which look
amazing love the vegetables I mean I
don't know if there's fat in that
dressing because you know she's kind of
into the low oil thing so I don't know
what's in that dressing but if not we
could use definitely some fat here and
because your name is high carb Hannah
I was definitely anticipating some more
carbs here where the carbs at Hannah but
I mean hey if you're gonna make up for a
dinner that's totally fine she had more
carbs at breakfast so as long as things
are kinda like balanced throughout the
day I'm happy it looks really good
alright moving on to snack time I'm
still editing so I'm just gonna have a
snack of some blueberries and this
banana
I feel like editing isn't a lot of
physical work but it's so mentally
draining but I just need you all to keep
me going so this is the perfect little
midday snack for me so there they are
there are the energizing carbs and that
totally makes sense we had less carbs at
the lunch more carbs for the snack I get
it now let's look at dinner dinner time
I really want to make pasta because I
feel like I haven't really had a lot of
substance today like I had fruit and
then I had a smoothie with the oats and
salad I just need like a lot of carbs
and protein so I love that she kind of
has the intuition to say you know I have
eaten pretty light today maybe
busy or like I just didn't think to like
put things together that were like super
satisfying and I've arrived at dinner
and I'm really hungry and I need
something really satisfying and hearty
and that's great I mean like of course
in a perfect world you'd say spread
those calories though throughout the day
but being an intuitive eater means not
fussing over each and every meal or
snack and trying to make it perfect our
body is so intuitive that if we don't
eat a whole lot at one meal we're gonna
make up for it shortly after and
sometimes that means like the next day
or the next meal or the next snack
oftentimes you know if we have like a
light day of eating the next day we'll
make up for it by eating more or if we
eat a lot one day cuz maybe it's a
holiday or we go for dinner or we just
have a bigger appetite that day some
nice the next day we might eat less so
as long as we're focusing on trying to
get a balanced diet over the course of
let's say a week we're in really good
shape it tolls it's super high in
protein so I like to use it and the
taste and texture is pretty good and
then I had some canned artichokes some
sun-dried tomatoes and frozen spinach in
my fridge so I threw that in there with
some of the vo life Parmesan cheese I
didn't add any dressing to this I
basically just put half a lemon some
garlic powder and Italian seasoning in
there and mix it all together and then
just throw this into a bowl then I just
added some fresh chopped tomatoes in
there stirred all of it together and
that was it it was pretty easy using
everything that I had on hand so this
hat looks amazing and now I'm super
craving pasta but I just want to say
that like I think it's funny because she
started off the meal like prep saying
how she really wanted to get in lots of
protein like a higher protein dinner as
well as carbs of course and yes she's
using like a lentil pasta which is
higher in protein but it's still
consider this more of like a moderate
protein meal and if she really want to
kind of beef it up and take it to the
next level she could throw in some tofu
or some white beans or even just like a
healthy sprinkling of nutritional yeast
would really help things out I get that
her name is high carb Hannah so maybe
her standards for like high protein are
slightly different than mine but if
was what she was looking for and I was
her dietitian I would say hey you could
make some of these adjustments to boost
the protein a little bit more to lose
weight I did totally quit intermittent
fasting it had over time really negative
effects on me not like physically but
very emotionally and in other way so I
really like the Hana touched on the fact
that she was quitting intermittent
fasting because it just wasn't good for
her emotional health
Hannah's talked a lot about how she's
really tried to become more in tune with
her body and her eating and like I have
super props for the woman for saying
that you know hey this this diet that is
really popular right now I'm really in
you know just was not working for me I
will also say that there is evidence
that intermittent fasting and some
people can cause decreased energy lack
of concentration fatigue irritability
etc so I'm really not surprised that
Hannah kind of was struggling
emotionally with the concept also since
Hannah mentioned that she's really
trying to conceive I would agree that
interim fasting is not super supportive
of improving fertility in fact research
suggests that women during Ramadan who
are fasting increased their cortisol
levels which interferes with gone Ando
trope and releasing hormone which can
interfere with ovulation and therefore
make it more difficult to get pregnant
well we don't have a whole lot of human
research that are specifically on
intrument fasting and fertility I did
find one rat study that was particularly
concerning the study found that after 12
weeks
the female fasting rats LH which is a
reproductive hormone plummeted their
estradiol skyrocketed their leptin which
is the satiety hormone was six times
lower than normal and their ovaries
shrank what the I know that I often
emphasize so we cannot extrapolate human
outcomes from rat outcomes
however as someone who struggled with
infertility and legitimately would try
anything to make my journey easier as
well as just somebody who knows the
dieting in general is not healthy and
does not work I wouldn't risk it ok
folks let's take a look at Hannah's
macronutrient
tribution in this day Hannah's getting
about 1552 calories 28% is coming from
fat 56% from carbs and 16% from protein
so this is all technically within the
normal average ranges when it comes to
the macronutrient distribution however
for an active young woman who's trying
to conceive I would say it is on the low
side for the calories okay so let's
start by talking about what I like about
Hannah's diet first of all she includes
a wide variety of healthy foods even
though hannah is plant-based she does
try to incorporate a nice variety of
foods that have lots of good fats and
antioxidants and fiber and protein if I
was being MIT Piketty I could say hey
maybe throw in an extra snack or two
especially because the calories are so
low she definitely has room to sneak one
or two more snacks in there ideally
something with some fiber protein or
healthy fats in there to kind of keep
her satisfied so for example she could
have some chia pudding in between you
know breakfast and lunch or maybe she
could do something hummus with
vegetables just something to kind of
boost up that protein that I know she
mentioned wanting to kind of get a
little bit more of while her diet
definitely does seem highly nutritious I
know Hannah mentioned that she is trying
to conceive so just making sure that she
is kind of getting enough calories and
maintaining high enough body fat to do
so would really be my recommendation I
don't know anything about really her
fertility journey I don't know what her
diagnosis is but if it is something like
a chay or a hypothalamic amenorrhea
which I talked about earlier in my
Stephanie butter more video then that
would definitely be my recommendation is
to really focus on getting those
calories up number two her recipes are
accessible and easy I really love
watching youtubers what ate in a day
where I walk away having not only seen
like step by step a whole recipe start
to finish but yeah I feel so inspired to
do something like that at home and I
feel like I can so that's how I feel
after watching some of Hannah's videos
like that smoothie oatmeal concoction
awesome that salad I am totally stealing
that because now I'm craving like a
ginger dressing so I just really love
that
those recipes included or required any
expensive supplements or really hard to
find ingredients they were all things
that I think pretty much anyone could
really pull off and number three she's
talking about taking her prenatal
supplements so you know I always applaud
these youtubers when they discussed
their supplement regime and especially
in the context of kind of trying to
conceive I definitely think it is an
important piece here some of the really
important nutrients during pregnancy are
while trying to conceive of course our
iron and folate both of which she's
getting in her diet and also in the
prenatal she didn't mention vitamin D or
omega-3 both of which are also very
important when trying to conceive and
pregnant in pregnancy but I will touch
more on that just momentarily now I want
to talk about what I don't like in
Hannah's video so first of all I would
say her calories are just too low you
know the average woman needs about 2000
calories and that is an average and I
don't really know her like activity
level I don't know her weight or height
or really like any anthropometrics like
that so it's very hard for me to make a
very specific recommendation here I'm
not her dietitian however I would say
that you know for active woman and I've
seen in some of her other videos that
she lifts pretty heavy and she works out
this probably just isn't enough calories
especially for fertility sake again she
mentions trying to conceive and tried
really hard and I don't know her
diagnosis but if there is some
hypothalamic amenorrhea one thing I
talked about in my H a video and my all
end video is that the recommendation can
be you know starting as you know as the
minimum of 2500 calories and there is no
maximum for how many calories in order
to restore your cycle I don't know if
she's ovulating or menstruating I don't
know what her diagnosis is however for
those of you guys who are watching at
home and trying to conceive definitely
look at your caloric levels and make
sure you're eating enough number two I
want to talk about some of the
misguidance
around fertility and body fat so Hanna
talks in this video about how she's no
longer focusing so much on numbers or
weight loss yet she still titles the
video what I in a day to stay
she also has a lot of videos that are
kind of like weight loss guides or
weight loss cheat sheets or the easiest
way to lose weight etc and I know in
another video she talks about like how
how she gained weight and she kind of
feels good but then also talks about how
she's still kind of measuring body fat
and things like that which is still
considered body manipulation and not
body kindness a lot of experts believe
that for fertility the optimal BMI range
is between 22 to 24 which is actually at
the upper end not the lower end of what
is considered a normal BMI
for a woman who is 5 6 for example that
would be somewhere between 140 and 145
pounds so I know that BMI is grossly
flawed but what I want people to take
away is that we actually want to not
fear body fat when it comes to trying to
get pregnant
we need that body fat when it comes to
trying to grow feed and nourish another
human being
number 3 there's a lack of omega-3s and
vitamin D in her diet now when it comes
to analyzing Hannah's overall omega-3
intakes she's getting about 750
milligrams of total Omega threes which
is just below the recommendation of
about 1100 so I'm less worried about
total omega-3s
but I'm not seeing a whole lot of is the
EPA and DHA Omega threes that are really
important during pregnancy so for most
women who are not plant-based these
would come from kind of marine sources
like things like salmon or trout herring
mackerel or omega-3 supplement that has
at least 300 milligrams of DHA for my
plant-based mom's you'd be looking at an
algae based omega-3 supplement that has
DHA as for vitamin D there just isn't a
whole lot of great sources in the diet
especially a plant-based diet so
including a supplement in your regime
might be a really good idea
research suggests that including a
vitamin D supplement can improve your
chances of conceiving it also has a lot
of benefits during pregnancy including
reducing the chances of preeclampsia and
postpartum bleeding so I would
definitely recommend Hanna and anybody
at home to speak to your doctor about a
vitamin D supplement especially if
you're not getting a lot in the diet or
you're trying to conceive
and finally there is a lot of
problematic nutrition information on the
channel so I found this video in
particular pretty benign when it comes
to misguided nutrition information who
ever there were other videos on her
channel like a lot of them about celery
juice curing all sorts of stuff like
acne and strep throat um no sure celery
is packed with fiber vitamin C vitamin K
potassium etc but the research that we
have on celery juice being a cure-all is
limited
we know that the flavonoids and phenolic
compounds that are found in foods like
celery may play a role of reducing the
risk of cardiovascular disease cancer
diabetes etc but we really cannot make
any conclusive claims a lot of these
studies have been done on rats and
they're super small so really difficult
to make any recommendations from them
not to mention a lot of these same
phenolic compounds and flavonoids are
found in lots of other fruits and
vegetables I mean I don't know who the
celery lobbyists are out there but
they've done a good job not to mention a
lot of the beneficial compounds aka
fibers found in celery are removed when
you juice it so I say if you like the
taste of celery and I do sometimes I
mean especially with like peanut butter
on it just eat the food and skip the $10
juice from the juice bar just saying in
conclusion I think that Hannah's diet is
pretty well-balanced especially as far
as plant-based diets go I also think
she's got lots of great ideas that are
accessible and easy and definitely
inspiring she's also on the right track
when it comes to motherhood she's taking
her prenatal vitamins she's stopping the
intermittent fasting however I do think
there are a few things that she could do
to really up her chances of conceiving
mainly I think it's making sure that
she's getting enough calories and fat
and some of those really important
nutrients in her day to maintain a
healthy pregnancy so I would encourage
Hannah to continue with intuitive eating
and improving her relationship with food
I know Hannah talks about listening to
her body and intuitive eating however
her channel is still peppered with a lot
of diet culture and a lot of information
that is not backed up by science I do
think that for a lot of youtubers what
they say and
with regards to their relationship with
food is sometimes at odds and I think it
would be helpful for Hannah to do like a
deep dive and try to evaluate some of
those deep-seated beliefs that she may
have around food and her body and fat
etc and I think that would really really
support her fertility journey honestly I
wish her all the best luck and lots of
baby dust so guys I hope you enjoyed
this video if you did be sure to give it
the thumbs up leave me a comment below
if you have any questions about
fertility I will definitely be covering
it an upcoming video or any youtuber so
you want me to review subscribe to the
channel and I'll see you next time on
Abby's kitchen bye
[Music]
[Music]